of course there's a big elephant in the
room always which is called AI yeah
right and so I know that you are an
expert at this subject
and we are going we're living now in
this very interesting times of new uh AI
systems coming online pretty much every
couple of weeks
so
I kind of um to me that whole debate
about
what is it what is artificial
intelligence where is it going what
should we do about it
needs an influx of this type of
considerations that we've just been
talking about
that for instance the idea that
inspiration creativity doesn't come from
accumulation of knowledge because
obviously child a child has not yet
accumulated knowledge and yet the great
ones are on record saying that a child
has a capacity
to to create
and an adult
credits the inner child the inner child
yeah uh for this capacity to create as
an adult you see that's kind of weird if
we take the point of view
that everything is computation
everything is accumulation of knowledge
that just bigger and bigger data sets
finer and finer neural networks and then
we will be able to replicate human
consciousness if we take that point of
view then what I just said kind of
doesn't fit because obviously a child
has not been fed any training data as
far as we know yet they're perfectly
capable of of you know of distinguishing
between cats and dogs for instance and
stuff like that but much more than that
they're also capable of that
you know wide-eyed in a sort of
perspective
so does can it really be captured that
perspective that sense of or can it
really be captured by competition alone
I actually I don't know the answer so
I'm not sort of trying to
uh to present a particular point of view
understand to question
um any theory that starts out by saying
life is this or Consciousness is this
because when you look more closely you
recognize that there are some other
things at play which do not quite fit
the narrative
and it's hard to know where they come
from it's it's also possible that the
evolutionary process has created
is the very it is computation and the
child is actually not a blank slate but
the result of one of the most incredible
several billion year old computations
uh that
that had explored all kinds of aspects
of of life on Earth
of of war and love and Terror and
ambition and violence and invention all
of that from the bacteria to today so
like that young child is not is not a
blank slate they call me they're they're
actually they hold within them the
knowledge of several billions of years
right the question is whether as a child
you carry that in the form of the kind
of computational algorithms that we are
aware today you see what what strikes me
as unlikely
is that
how should I put it how interesting that
you know we you you are a computer
scientist and there are other people
come I have studied computer science so
I know a little bit
and so it's tempting to say
oh
the whole world
is computer science or is based can be
explained by computer science yes why
because it makes me feel good because I
have mastered it I have learned it my
ego is very happy yeah and people come
to me and and they look up to me and
they Revere me kind of like priests in
the world in old days when the religion
was Paramount wonder when you would tend
to explain things in theological
religious terms today science has
progressed there are fewer people who
kind of buy into religion official
religion you know so
we have this urge I suppose to to
explain and to know and to dissect and
to analyze and to conceptualize which is
a wonderful quality that we have and we
should definitely pursue that but I find
it a little bit unlikely
that the universe is just exactly what I
have learned
and not something that I don't know you
see
well there's a lot of interesting
aspects of the current large language
models that one perspective of it I
think speaks to the love and math that
you talk to which is
they're trained on
human data from the internet
so at its best a large language model
like gpt4
captures the magic of The Human
Condition on its full display it's full
complexity
as it's mimicking it's trying to
compress all the weirdness of humans
of all the debates and discussions the
perspectives all the different ways that
people approach solving different
problems all of that compressed so we
live we're in each individual ants we
only have like we have a family we
interact with a few little ants and here
comes AI That's able to summarize like a
tldr report of humanity and that's the
beauty of it so I embrace it but I
wonder I'm very impressed by it I wonder
if
they can be very impressive meaning
way more impressive in being able to
fake or simulate or emulate a human fake
I'm glad you mentioned that because
that's just it seems to be the Mantra
it's just fake it till you make it yeah
isn't it isn't that what we all do
though no well yes we do that but we
also do other things we can be truly in
love we can be truly inspired when it is
not fake I do believe call me a romantic
okay but I do believe
and this is a very good I'm glad you're
putting it in these terms because I've
had conversations like that that yeah
fake it till you make it but that's like
that's what humans do yes we do that but
not all the time so and that is
debatable because also I speak from my
own experience and that's where the
first person perspective comes in the
subjective view I cannot prove to you
for instance or anyone else that there
are certain moments in my life where I
am genuine I am pure so to speak when
it's not faking it but I do I do have a
tremendous
a certainty of it and that's a
subjective certainty now I am as a
scientist I'm also trained to give more
um credibility to objective arguments
that another things that can be
reproduced things that I can demonstrate
that I can show
but as I get older there we go as I get
more mature hopefully you know
I'm starting to question why I am not
giving as much
credibility to my subjective
understanding of the world the kind of
the first person perspective when
actually modern science has already sold
on that you know quantum mechanics
has shown unambiguously that the
Observer is always involved in the
observation
likewise yodel's incompleteness
ethereums to me
shows how essential
is the Observer of a mathematical theory
for one thing that's the one who chooses
the axioms and we can talk about this in
more detail likewise Einstein's
relativity where
time is relative to The Observer for
instance that's brilliant you're just
describing all these different scales
The Observer what they Observer